of all the Disney sequels I've reviewed
so far lady in the Tramp too seems to be
the closest in spirit to the original
now that's not saying a ton seeing how I
thought the original was only okay let's
be fair I think it was meant to be kind
of a smaller movie anyway as soon as its
sequel starts you'd swear you were in
the exact same film the animation is
really top-notch and looks eerily
similar to the original I don't know why
they throw all their effort into these
lady in the tram films I mean they're
just dogs walking around why would you
make them look this good
but they do man it's beautiful to look
at the story itself ranges from generic
to actually kind of okay but again for a
lady in the Tramp movie it's not like
I'm expecting anything spectacular here
the film takes place not even a year
after the original lady and the train
still have puppies and they seem to be a
happy family but one of them seems to
get into a lot of trouble that beans
skin voice distractingly so by Scott
wolf yeah look at this thing you expect
a cute little kid voice to come out of
it something high-pitched but instead
what do we get but I want to run wild
and free like a real dog God does that
not fit I go wherever I want do whatever
I please you know the only reason they
went with this voice is so they could
get a semi celebrity in there and it
just doesn't work but faithfully the
rest of the voice actors aren't that bad
as he wants to run away from home and
join a bunch of junkyard dogs one of
them named Angel played by Alyssa Milano
takes him under her wing and shows him
the ways of the outdoors but things get
tricky when scamp doesn't know where he
belongs in the home life or the outdoor
life it gets even trickier when it looks
like Angel wants a home life and even
had a home life plus had her heart
broken many times before and even
trickier when the leader of the junkyard
dogs has it in for his father yeah it
sounds like a semi reversal of the first
film and not really too interesting but
actually they do quite a bit with it the
pacing in this film is a lot slower than
other Disney sequels and it's very
welcomed much like the original there's
this real elegance and color to it the
backgrounds are just glowing and when a
character goes through something they
don't just say a line and then run away
they actually kind of sit there and let
the moment sink in the songs are
actually rather fitting
okay there's an occasional lame lyric
here and there but the style matches the
time period perfectly there's even a
ragtime in it and for these types of
songs they're actually done pretty well
does it all work no there's definitely
the cliches that you can see coming and
certainly a groaner line here or there
and I really didn't get what age
everybody was supposed to be I mean okay
scamp is supposed to be a puppy but they
get an adult voicing it well okay maybe
he's still a little kid but Alyssa
Milano voices the other maybe puppy they
don't really make it clear she's a puppy
maybe she's just a small dog but there's
clearly a romance blooming between him
so okay maybe she has a puppy but then
she talks about how she's been in and
out of five families five families you
can't be that young and go through five
families but okay give the bath of the
doubt maybe she has me she is still a
puppy the leader of the junkyard dogs
clearly an adult has the hots for her
always calling her his girl how does
this work
so yeah little scenes like that and kind
of a phoned-in climax make it lame at
some points but truth be told I was
actually kind of impressed with how much
it felt like the original Lady and the
Tramp they do try to make you feel
something they do show the dilemmas the
characters are going through they do
take the time for it I can't really see
it's great cuz I don't think the first
film or this one were meant to be really
great they're supposed to be small
elegant Pleasant little movies okay
there's definitely problems that hold me
back from liking it as much as the first
one I mean the first one did have a
little bit more of an edge to it but I
think if you're someone that actually
wanted to see a sequel to lady in the
Tramp this'll do you fine if this is a
story you for some reason really want to
see continue well I say check it out it
might be an adequate spin-off to dig
your positive
[Music]
you